Okay,
we should be live here.
Let me set the title of this real quick
or the
Wait, did it work?
Yeah.
we were very close to having this
working with 10% domain knowledge.
possibly we can solve this with sampling
bias.
So I think that the plan for today is
for the first chunk we're going to see
whether we can get stable
15 solves with 10% domain knowledge and
then we're going to work on uplading
that last
quite tired today.
Was it 12? Probably going to do like a
5ish hour, 4ish hour stream today.
Okay, so they're getting added by
rewards.
sampling is uniform.
Okay. So, we have to essentially figure
out right now
You can see what essentially has
happened here.
So, we've taken a big hit to uh the
quality of
our latching.
Okay, let's let's sort of think about
all the various options here, right? We
could bias the sampling somehow.
We're storing segments by the correct
metric already.
We could try to admit them by advantage
and try to like fix both things at the
same time.
Now the freshest segmented mission's
already correct. Hey Jess,
we're trying to finish up the algorithm
today.
What end is the best indicator that now
go generalizes well across different M?
Generally mazes and 2048
have been our best ones for that.
Breakout is the quickest end that's like
you probably haven't completely broken
stuff.
Doing better on breakout sometimes means
that you do better in a lot of places
actually quite often but definitely not
as consistent as mazes or 2048.
This was just like the first dumb thing
I thought of. We'll see if it makes any
sense.
Once we have this question solved,
there's really only one question left,
The key difficulty
at the moment is going to be that um
we do not have a way to refresh
advantage.
This dumb sampling change may have
worked good enough.
If so, we'll commit this.
Yeah, I'm a little stuck on the whole
advantage
the whole advantage thing.
The core issue is that there's no way to
there's no good way to refresh
advantage, right?
There is I mean I could it would make
the algorithm more complicated.
Does this get us a 15 solve? This does
look pretty stable to be fair.
fun was good this morning, Jess. I'm
just very tired.
I probably need to just eat a little bit
more for the next couple days and I'll
be good.
I'm already down like five, six pounds
in the last three weeks.
This will latch right at the end, won't
it?
Yeah.
There we go. That's the 15 solve.
I think that's good enough for the
baseline
to start on the advantage stuff.
Let me commit this.
Today is just going to be like a slow,
thoughtful sort of a stream on the
algorithm, I suppose.
Like I'm tired, but my mind is actually
pretty clear.
I don't know. It might be better for me
to take like a week off and do cut at
maintenance
cuz I do remember from last summer after
a few weeks it was just real tough
to think to like do anything
or even just like a less of aggressive
cut. This is like psychotically
aggressive cut. I can pretty much just
eat whatever and not stuff myself and
I'll still be um
down in pills.
This thing is not going to find
anything. But
the fact that this thing won't find
anything, this will at least
act to convince me I'm not missing
anything really obvious.
the these things. It's like there's like
sophisticated thousand things that are
like very stupid.
This is actually maybe the most
reasonable.
If you're taking two courses, an
operating systems course and a databases
course, you shouldn't be taking other
things.
Wait, are you trying to pick one of the
two?
If there's not a big quality difference
in quality for um profs, I would
definitely do operating systems.
Unless it's like a systems course in
database architecture, that could be
kind of interesting. But if it's
basically going to be here SQL, like
screw that.
right,
it's SQL. Yeah, screw that in. I mean, I
guess it's useful for applied stuff, but
that type of thing is way easier to pick
up than like operating systems is.
No, Jess. Actually, SQL is so ass that
people are vibe coding their SQL queries
at this point for the most part.
Like
learning to build SQL, that would be an
interesting course. learning to use SQL
not remotely.
Well, Roger, it's funny because I like
my Stanford systems courses were so bad
that I didn't take any of the advanced
ones and I thought system was for like
stuck up stuck up imbeciles
because my systems courses were awful.
Um,
well,
so I actually didn't even I didn't take
an operating systems course. I didn't
take a compiler course. I probably would
really enjoy those if they were
reasonably taught.
I will say the algorithms courses were
pretty crap.
Aside from the intro ones, the advanced
algorithms were very like just pedantic
and dumb.
Um,
well,
20 mil per. Actually, I wouldn't be
surprised, Jess. I wouldn't just say,
"Oh, it's bad cuz 20 mil perms.
Your thing might actually scale with
capacity." Roger. I really didn't enjoy
almost any of my classes, to be honest
with you. Um, I have a couple
exceptions. It's not like I just hate
all classes. There were a few courses I
took that were really good and really
useful, but the vast majority of courses
were just very poorly taught to the
point that they were no longer they were
more frustrating than useful.
And I have a very high tolerance for
frustration.
like if you're really caring about
grades in university, you're missing the
point.
Okay, we're going to see if this works.
This is the last piece of domain
knowledge removed.
So, this is now this is basically no
domain knowledge.
Like, I know some basics and I just use
them very well. That's it.
It's like, you know, in martial arts,
like I know a couple kicks, but I'm
really good at them.
Well,
there's a little more to it just than
that. Like the way I approached the
research was something I've learned over
um well well over a decade.
I'm quite good at drawing connections
between things.
I also sort of model the quality of
works by modeling the
modeling the likely mindset of the
authors.
That's very useful.
It's very funny because a lot of the
things I do, it's just like they seem
kind of obvious.
You have a dream. We're going to solve
everything, spirit. That's it. Solve
everything.
Awesome. Utopian sci-fi future and
whatever.
It's more pruning I would say Jess
and then like whatever is left must be
the way to go.
I'm just I don't know there's like very
basic first principles logic that
somebody will tell me X and I'll say
well okay X implies Y implies Z and I
know Z is false so
it just basic stuff like that
I have a very good memory for like a
very odd category of things as Well,
like when layer norm wasn't working, I
immediately remembered the paper from 10
years ago that I had done on
recurrent highway nets and I remembered
not wanting to use layer norm there and
I remembered like highway connections
working.
I also don't like this fixed decay idea.
I don't
This might not even be the issue No.
putting 40 to 50 hour work weeks during
college.
Uh because I grew up working 100 plus
hour weeks. So, like when I was working
80 or 90 in college, it was not that
hard.
And noticeably, you'll see that I don't
do that [ __ ] anymore.
It's very, very bad for open-ended work
in addition to just being kind of
miserable.
I also got dramatically better um since
the end of my PhD even.
I guess it was kind of like I I already
had all the pieces
built up throughout my PhD and then it
was like a relatively simple thing to
put them together afterwards.
Like getting more into systems felt very
natural.
Like stripping out all this bloated crap
felt very natural.
version of working 80 hours a week
during college is literally alien talk.
I mean, 80 hours a week is 12 hours a
day, 5 days a week, and then 10 on
weekends.
Like 80 hours is just working
constantly,
uh, not having time for anything else,
but still basically being able to get
good sleep.
100 hours is like having no time for
anything else and also not getting good
sleep.
I don't feel like it's the switch went
off and I'm just lazy now. I've done
very very hard things in the last few
years. Like
I mean a lot of the things with puffer
were very challenging because you don't
have like um it's not like somebody's
just sticking things in front of you
where you know what you need to do to
get there. You're doing something that's
never been done before. And the types of
pressures and stresses from that are
very different.
I've also done a whole bunch of athletic
things that I would have never dreamed
of when I was younger,
things that are just brutally difficult.
Um,
I don't think I've gotten lazier by any
means. It's more so just that the work
has been different
and different work requires a different
approach.
Like the thing that matters right now is
that I make the correct assumptions on
this algorithm and I don't overlook
anything important.
If I were to do this for 16 hours
straight for instance, I guarantee you I
would start overlooking important
details that would then end up costing
me more time.
So somehow advantage is not getting us
the right data into our buffer.
I don't know. a nish. I don't think it's
like, oh, I've gotten less energy as
I've gotten older or anything.
I honestly the points in which I've had
the least energy are the points where
I'm just like stuck working on [ __ ]
I think the reason that people tend to
have less energy is they just get stuck
working on [ __ ]
like you don't have autism and you don't
have ADHD because you're [ __ ] bored.
Like that's normal.
If anything, it's very weird to be able
to force yourself to concentrate on um
work that you have to actively think
about that is also completely boring.
I've had stretches of my life where
basically I would be incapable of
reading a single page of text I found
boring.
Like if I were to open up a paper and
try to read the first page, if I found
the paper boring, I literally would not
be able to read the first page. I'd just
like space out, space out, space out,
and an hour later just give up.
Well, hot is a little bit crazy as well
in I don't think you want to have him as
your see see I'm totally saying your
honor
most of us are forced to at least do
some of that rearrange things to do last
of it.
you got any cool new shower results or
anything?
We're down to um 10%
domain knowledge required by this new
algorithm.
I'm working on literally the last thing
that we need to remove before this
algorithm works without domain
knowledge. And then we can tune it. And
then we can try it on other ends.
Do you guys see is it clear to people
why um the
method by which we put data into the
buffer cannot depend on score. Is that
obvious people to people or no?
Here, I'll let this run something and
I'll explain, I guess, while um while
this runs in case that's not obvious
because there's a distinction here.
You're actually allowed to use the score
of the environment
as a general purpose part of your
algorithm.
However, you're not allowed to use it
everywhere.
We're letting it add some stupid
diagnostics.
I'll explain the distinction in a
moment.
I just want to have the run going
because then I'll have five, six minutes
to do so.
What's this, Jess?
Also, I actually um I know somebody who
was talking about RL plus Galcon.
There's actually one dude I knew who was
super interested in this where um he
might be running the competition
actually. If he's participating in it,
you're screwed. He's literally the best
programmer I've ever met.
know. Yeah, I do know his name. Let me
uh I'll message you in a bit. Hang on.
New number of Okay, here. Let me explain
real quick the um the thing that I was
talking about though. So, tab in. Um
so what we showed with our earlier
experiments
that were using domain specific
knowledge on Soabon
we showed that if you have your standard
RL algorithm okay and you allow some of
your environments to reset to previously
seen states and just run the normal
policy from there.
That's the difference in the algorithm
is that some environments can reset to
previously seen states. We showed that
by retaining a very small set of states,
even a single trajectory segment,
you can basically perfectly solve any
sparse exploration problem.
So if only you know which state states
to reset to,
you solve basically any sparse
exploration task.
It's a ludicrously powerful method.
So now the entire thing that we've been
doing for the past several days is
trying to come up with an increasingly
general way to do that.
And the way that we're currently
attempting to do it
is we are using the advantage associated
with a segment
to decide which segments to stick into
our buffer of states.
So we store the entire se segment and we
put it into a state buffer.
And then when you sample a state from
that segment, you can sample any of the
states. You don't have to start from the
beginning of the segment.
Um, if you get a higher episode return
starting from that state, you can
replace the segment that you sampled
with the better outcome.
This uses score, right? You're
essentially saying that if you're
starting uh if you have a segment and
you're starting from a previously seen
state and you get a better outcome, you
can update the buffer with that better
outcome.
This is general because given that you
are already in uh a specific state of
the environment,
you pretty much always want to have
higher episode return.
There's a little bit of opportunity for
RNG hacking,
but not a lot.
RNG hacking meaning like just trying it
a bunch of times until you happen to get
a very lucky solve. not under the
policy, but because like a simple
example of this would be you keep
hitting the hitting the boss reset to
right before you hit the boss and then
um as soon as you get like a high damage
number, right, that's the segment you
keep.
The reason I say that there's not a lot
of potential for RNG hacking here is
because you have to redo the full
segment every time and we change the RNG
value each time as well. So, you can't
just like exhaustively try all the
options until you find one that's good
RNG.
Now, the reason that you can't use the
reward to select which segment should go
into the buffer
is that different episodes are not going
to have the same potential for reward.
Very simple example of this is any game
with procedurally generated levels. Some
runs are going to be easier than others.
You don't want to fill your buffer with
just the easiest levels.
Therefore, you cannot use reward as the
metric by which you decide to put stuff
into your buffer. That is domain
specific.
Segment size is determined by sweep and
it matters incredibly.
It's the same as the horizon parameter
for BPTT
and uh it's one of the most correlated
parameters with uh policy score across a
large number of tasks as of puffer 4.
So that is why we need to have an
advantage based metric. I mean we could
use something other than advantage if
anybody has ideas.
But that's why we cannot use score as
the metric to decide what data to keep.
Now the reason that advantage is a
little bit tricky. So first of all it
seems to just not be putting in as good
segments. I'm going to figure that out.
The real difficulty with advantage is
it's tied to the policy at time of
collection.
So advantage is based on starting in a
state and then assuming that you're
going to follow the current policy from
there.
So is the value function for that
matter, right? The a normal value
function without an advantage estimate
is just predicting if I follow the
policy from the current state, what is
going to be my future expected return?
That's all it predicts.
The only way to update this reasonably
would be to start from the same original
state.
But then, you know, if you're sampling a
very sparse problem, you're probably not
actually going to get as good of a a
reward. So, you would have to do
something more complicated like if I
sample from the starting state and I get
a better equal or better reward, then I
update the advantage,
which I suppose we can do that if we
have to.
It's a little janky.
We are on 13 score here. Oops. One
moment.
Sorry. Housekeeper.
Um
13 out of 15 score with no domain
knowledge. Okay, I do think we can make
this dramatically better though.
No. Canvert you. That's not how that
works. We're doing fine, but
Not ranking the next level solve is the
best data. Interesting.
don't even know. Yeah, that is
especially
where um
if you're earning any reasonable amount
of money,
incredibly worthwhile.
basically still predicting discounted
return.
Yeah, I have no ideas here other than
like, yeah, whatever. Add logs, figure
out why. I thought about this for a bit.
I don't know why this would happen.
We'll see.
I just need some diagnostics at this
point.
Also, why does this thing keep blowing
up?
Oh, the stream post.
I don't know if I'm in good company. Uh,
here.
Hello YouTube folks.
We are very slowly chipping away at this
algorithm.
If we can figure out why precisely
advantage isn't giving us the expected
stuff in buffer, I think I can solve the
other problem.
So I think with a couple diagnostics, we
should be okay here.
I don't know why I scrolled this. Like I
there's probably not even any cool
research, right?
Advantage is not going to be highest on
the last state.
Now we'll see it'll interact with self
plays frozen pool
victory snapshots produced
your policy and the opponent's p.
Yeah, Jess, we just have to make it so
that um the states that we sample are
with the current set of opponents,
right?
See, the funny thing is it literally
just doesn't understand how advantage
works. Adds in bad diagnostics.
Me,
that's what I get, I suppose. But
whatever.
This will be very cool. Actually, we
should give um what do they bring now?
Melee switch with scythe for the inferno
environment that we have. It'd be very
cool to give him a melee switch with
scythe.
Huh?
Pre-chaining recurring neuralance
without recurrence.
Just use linear recurrence.
Wait, this is this is a car.
Oh.
That's cool. The car was uh I mean this
is my lab.
Let's give it a
You can't just stick stuff on archive
and not tweet like not tweet it though.
You got to freaking tweet your stuff.
Hey, I know that, dude.
All right. Blah blah blah. We rerun this
with new diagnostics.
See if there's any cool research.
Okay,
we get diagnostics and then we go back
to thinking about stuff cuz I have um
uh I have no idea why this is happening.
Uh this is not the type of thing I can
solve by thinking about it. This is the
type of thing I need with di I need
diagnostics for. And once we have those
diagnostics,
we can probably solve it quickly. And uh
then we're on the last like the last
thing we need. It's pretty good.
Research.
Okay. What we're going to do is this is
long overdue.
no research.
I leave all the um indie game dev stuff
on the timeline because at least when
there's no cool research, you get to see
stuff like this.
Okay.
Well,
um that's about all that's on timeline
today. No other research.
Okay.
So, the plan is figure out why advantage
is not tracking.
Why is advantage not tracking the
frontier
at the moment? Figure out how to get it
to track the frontier. Whatever changes
we need to make.
Figure out the retention policy
and then iterate a little bit from there
until it's nice and stable.
The fact that this works at all is kind
of cool because this is still completely
untuned.
Oh, wait. That's Spencer. Thoughts on
clinging with DR
instead of DR from beginning?
Let me get my Discord open.
What's the problem, Spencer?
Is it too hard to learn domain
randomized or like what's going on?
No, I think Spencer that it would be
the CL thing that we did was different.
Remember remember the CL thing that we
did originally?
You can do that under DR, right? So just
do them both at the same time.
We're adapting to target
too hard from beginning.
I mean, you could throw it into the
sweep, I guess. Yeah, it might be that
we can increase it over time, but also,
uh, depending on what you're dring, keep
in mind, it's possible that you can
make, uh, you can make an environment
impossible if you dr it in an
unreasonable way.
Like one up here, like if we were doing
a drone for instance, if you make
gravity too strong for the drone to
literally like fly, you're going to
crash it and you're going to get a lot
of bad data into the buffer, right?
Where you working from?
Uh, I'm in California at the moment.
I spend most of my time
in Maryland and a little bit in Florida,
but sometime in the summer. California's
nice.
Oh yeah. Wait, who is this? Oh, this is
Jess. Let me see. Where is Jess?
I'm with chess.
How's everything going? Pretty decently.
This algorithm is a total pain. Uh I can
reexplain it in a moment. Let me just
answer a couple quick messages on the
side. First, we have we're down to like
uh 10% of the domain knowledge required
to solve the task. And there's like one
weird thing I'm figuring out to get rid
of the last bit. Buffer 5 is not What do
you mean finally up? I've been working
on it less than 3 weeks. Jeez.
Buffer four is up. That one took eight
months.
eh
just like if you want to do that, let me
know when there's an energy drink
sweetened with stevia
that's actually good and then may and
then send me a case of that and maybe
I'm I'm joking, Jess. Like, I don't
actually need this.
I've had enough energy drinks for one
lifetime.
So, if there's any sort of enzyme out
there that uh lets you process sugar
alcohols or you'd otherwise be
intolerant, let me know. That would make
life a lot easier.
Like I'm completely intolerant to sugar
alcohols and I don't know why
again convert. You could have just
literally written that whole end
yourself in maybe three four hours and
had more fun and learned more doing it.
I don't know if that's actually a thing
though, right? Like
I don't have any domain knowledge. Is
that even something that is
like like is that reaction even
something where an enzyme makes sense? I
don't freaking know.
I guess it is maybe and it like I don't
know if that's a enzyme like to digest
it or a blocker to figure out whatever
the heck else is happen. I don't [ __ ]
know. Had to actually learn some
bioformmally at some point.
I'm basically letting this thing do
whatever at the moment. This is purely
diagnostic.
Um, all we're trying to figure out is
why the highest advantage segments are
not coming from new level solves.
There is no known enzyme that breaks
down sugar alcohols.
see.
Okay. The whole point of the sugar
alcohols is that you don't actually
process them.
So, it's actually some It's actually
like bacteria processing them that
shouldn't be processing them.
Right. The whole point of all the zero
cal things is that you don't actually
digest them.
>> Yeah.
Like the whole point of zero cal stuff
is that you don't actually digest it.
but you don't actually break it down. So
any like you basically want it to be
inert is what you like you want it to be
inert completely inert in your digestive
system.
Yeah. So, that's also a thing, Jess. If
you could if you could get it break
broken down into something that you
don't process
uh without actually Yeah, that would
work as well, I think.
So basically you don't even need to know
the complex chemistry and what is
actually happening with the thing. You
just need to like all you need to know
is the subset of of in the subset of
stuff to be able to figure out like
something else that you can convert it
into that's likely to be more inert,
right?
I think I'm going to have fun like
actually learning bio stuff.
To be clear, learning bio stuff is not
going to be just like typing questions
into LLM. There will be formal study
probably on stream as well.
But that is on hold until RL is solved.
We solve one field at a time.
Um
Jess, you you have to be a little bit
careful with that though cuz it can be
like great, this works perfectly. Oops.
The byprod the byproducts cause cancer.
You're dead.
modified his stomach lining via crisper.
Wait, what
is that a thing?
Wait, I didn't think that you could
crisper
like a large chunk of existing cells.
I thought that's why they're mostly like
crispo on embry on embryos is the thing
because it's like one cell
or not even on embryos my bad on um on
eggs.
Can you crisper large numbers of cell?
Is that a thing?
Or did he like crisper a stem cell or
something?
What in the hell is that question that I
just got?
Habits.
That's not a habit, my guy. That's kind
of just normal.
Not that one specifically, but like
other distractions, you just remove
them.
Like here, the one thing I could never
kick was constantly watching YouTube on
my phone.
I can't watch YouTube on this phone.
Problem solved.
I think I handled that very well, Jess,
by restraining myself from not making
the obvious yo mama joke.
I just need this thing to parse me a
little bit of log of data.
Let's see if this gives us anything
plausible.
a pre-solve eight.
H.
Yeah, I don't know enough about how that
works. Jess,
can you like I didn't think you can
crisper large numbers of cells. Did he
like crisper some stem cell like stem
cells or something?
I want to know if it's getting high
advantage on levels that are already
fully solved. That should not be
possible.
Wait, what? Where is sending YouTube
videos? I'll Yeah, I'll check that.
Jess, here. Let me kick this off and do
one. I got a quick thing I got to do and
then we will continue.
All right, we'll run this. Do a couple
quick things while this experiment runs
and then we'll actually have to think
about the advantage function a little
bit. No biggie.
using single 5090.
A single 5090.
Um, puffer is very fast. In fact, it can
be about 3x faster than this. We just
have a bunch of crap logging overhead.
Oh yeah, this is one of the coolest gems
we have. Look at this. This thing has
like terraformed this whole end over the
last 7,900 time steps.
Pretty cool.
By the time it is stuck before level 12,
the selected can is 100% solved.
models are stupid as usual. Um, but
pretty much what's happening according
to this thing is that we're seeing high
advantage on levels we've already
solved, which shouldn't be possible.
Really shouldn't be possible.
That's what we have to figure out.
We spec
max number of GPUs.
I it could go very high just but like
the point of what we're doing here is we
assume that we can do it um with very
low amount of compute if we just don't
do the engineering in a way that's
completely stupid
until we're really proven otherwise.
Like most research, they just write
really stupid code and then they assume
that you need lots of GPUs because they
don't realize that they're just writing
really stupid code,
you know,
let's actually get some stuff done
today. So,
I mean, I'm kind of stuck with this
stupid debug loop until we um until we
at least have some sort of understanding
of how on earth the advantage is not
working as expected.
Okay, I suppose one thing that does
occur to me
using the max advantage in a segment
that could be really noisy.
What do we do? Do we use some
summed advantage in a segment?
What is happening here?
Reinforcement learning research.
Um, specifically I am working on a new
algorithm
that allows agents to directly set this
well to have the state of the
environment set to any previously seen
state.
Uh, there's a little bit of a bug. Well,
not really a bug. There's something with
the new algorithm I don't quite
understand. I'm just getting a bunch of
crappy diagnostics on it at the moment
before I make the next set of decisions.
Six solve on pendulum.
Upper lib is it's pretty good. It's
pretty good.
We're so close to having this new
algorithm as well. Man,
it's very very close.
I'm talking with um my buddy who works
on curriculum learning later tonight.
Oh, actually that means I have to end
the stream a little early because he
sent me one of his recent papers I have
to read and I can't read it on stream.
So probably in I'll probably stream like
another hour and a halfish record stream
today.
Yeah, it's not surprising to me though
that like you can basically just chuck
puffer at some previously very hard
problems and it works.
Like a lot of the games are a lot harder
than um these really impressive looking
control problems. They're actually quite
easy for
reasonably good RL.
Like a lot of the games are much much
harder. Um I guarantee you that SOaban
like any reasonable form of SOAN is much
harder than Pendulum. It's much harder
than like most actual robotics problems.
Um most like fancy looking games
research. I mean like so's really really
hard.
So if you don't do RL and you don't
really know how to think about what
makes a problem hard or easy
at a deep level
like results are like results that are
actually really impressive will look
like toys and results that are toys will
look really impressive.
It's just NVIM but I don't even have an
Envim tab open anywhere man. So like my
editor's envim but this is just um like
like a basic terminal print out I wrote
for puffer.
Uh basic terminal print out I wrote for
puffer.
It's not supposed to be like this.
If we figure out a version of advantage
that correlates well,
we still don't have a way to update that
advantage.
Yeah, but I do have a few different
methods I can try.
No, I think we'll be able to have a
version of that that's reasonable.
not RL research, but it looks
interesting. So, the way that this
stream works is I just do all of my
research live. Sometimes it's really
boring crap like this where we're just
chipping away at a very hard problem
until it eventually falls. Sometimes
it's like much more active and
interesting low-level engineering. We
did several months straight of CUDA dev
for Puffer 4. Sometimes it's building
fancy new simulators. Sometimes I'll
have papers open and I'll be doing
architecture research. Sometimes stuff
is fast and exciting. Sometimes it's
slow and slow is boring. But progress is
made either way and it all happens here.
So while this is currently one of the
slower bits of it, um we are pretty much
90% of the way now towards
a very very major algorithmic
breakthrough.
At least it should be. We're not going
to know the full extent of it until we
really polish it up and test it more
broadly. But we have the makings of a
very good algorithm There.
if the hypothesis here is that max
advantage is unstable.
some absolute advantage.
Maybe it is summed to absolute
advantage.
We'll try some positive. We'll try some
absolute depending on what this returns
us.
uh I'm not involved with that one crit.
A few of our
community members have been chucking
puffer at it. I think it's like a or
well it's a algorithms competition based
on Galcon.
You can go play that game online.
Yeah. So, as expected, this is not the
magic solution.
adding a crazy number of logs. Lovely.
Like I said, sometimes our stuff is just
kind of slow, right? Sometimes research
is sort of slow.
Um, I still find it funny how this thing
has like zero useful suggestions,
but it can hack together large amounts
of crappy C and CUDA quickly enough. So,
whatever.
Excuse
me.
Yeah, I know, Anish. It's awful.
I mean, the only other thing I can do is
just like not show it.
You're not supposed to have that many
log items.
Uh, so Anish, at one point I thought
Puffer was going to be a pure games
company and I was playing all of the
games of the biggest companies in order
to like see if we could do anything for
their games with RL.
And I will say I was actually pleasantly
surprised. I was playing the uh the no
build version of it. It's actually like
a perfectly serviceable fun game.
It's just like a like good battle royale
thing,
especially if you turn off um there's a
setting to like turn off all of the
awful
um
like DRM
music and stuff like all the awful like
integrated music and stuff. You can turn
all that crap off.
Buffer Eve Online would be very funny
and [ __ ] with shooters. I mean, I've
played um I played a good chunk of
Overwatch. I've played a good chunk of
Valerant. It's not my favorite genre.
Like, I've played a bunch of games. It's
just that uh other genres don't tend to
hold my attention anywhere near as well
as MMOs do.
played a lot of like the large games
you'd expect.
I do still occasionally play League.
Um I'm awful at that game, but it's
still fun.
Valerant silver dude as well. I think
low. No, I did get Did I get to silver
one? I think I did get to silver one at
one point, but I'm terrible at shooters.
I got to gold on it. Like gold is a tank
main on Overwatch. That was like peak.
I'm really not good at uh
those types of games.
Favorite character in Overwatch?
It was mostly maning raat.
It was Ryan, but uh
with all the new stuff, it's it's just
not that usable a lot of the time.
protein.
Still looking for your account.
Uh, Anish, it doesn't keep the VODs for
that long.
Might have them on YouTube. I think I do
have them on YouTube.
I'll send you it at one point. I also
had like all the Runescape streams from
um
what was it? I had the Runescape streams
from getting I think it was just the
elite helm and then at some point the
master's helm.
I think I did actually edit together all
the clips for the elite combat
achievements.
I'm not actually staring at them yet and
I'm not actually doing anything on this.
So the thing that's happening at the
moment I can sort of explain um
the version of this that works uses the
highest score segments and adds those to
the buffer. That is a domain specific
hack that will not transfer to a large
class of environments. I'm trying to
replace this with an advantage base
metric to add the highest advantage
segments to the buffer. For whatever
reason,
that change is not adding the highest um
the highest reward segments. It's
producing much worse
much worse buffer data. So
that's pretty difficult a pretty
difficult thing to understand what's
going on. So it's just a bunch of like
slow annoying back and forth logging
crap.
Unfortunately, the simplest task that I
could come up with that is still
meaningful or uh this research is like a
six minute loop. I couldn't get a 30
second task that I could solve because
the problem is any of the 30 second
solve tasks the puffer for baseline will
also solve.
So, this is the best thing I could come
up with for now. And uh we're pretty
pretty close to solved. Like couple last
questions. Yeah, this is on um 5.0-
CLX,
this version.
Do you know what is being selected?
Yeah, it's somehow the previous levels
still have pretty high advantage on
them, and I'm trying to figure out why.
To be fair, Anish, Florida is miserable
in the summer. And I say that as a
Florida state resident.
However, Florida would be a um
substantially better state if they do
manage to just wipe out the mosquito
population.
I'm hoping that that actually goes
through and works.
Like I don't think people who have not
been there don't like I don't think
people who have not been there
understand how bad it is
advantage depend on value prediction.
Yes, the value function is predicting
incorrect value. That is exactly what
advantage is advant. It's the error in
the value function prediction.
So that's precisely what you want to
use, right? You're telling it that um it
needs to spend more time on areas where
it currently has an incorrect value
function.
They don't want to write it because
Yeah, it's dumb.
I mean, I got burned. I got sunburned
real bad this past weekend. Uh, and I
was only out for three hours. I don't
know if you can maybe you can't see
this. Look how tan this segment is. This
is not the camera lighting. I actually
just have a stripe right there.
was out like in direct sun for three
hours. did a 20k in the Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, I I went out with a hat, but no
sunscreen.
I forget how badly burned I got from my
50k. Honestly, I was in so much pain
from that thing. Like I probably did get
super burned and just didn't notice it
cuz everything else hurt more
This is hilarious.
Domino's tweeting freaking Runescape.
right. $116 an hour for Blackwells.
Jesus.
Okay,
we'll see what's going on There.
I think ultimately this is just going to
end up being a slight change to the
advantage metric for all of this crap,
but it's really not easy to get decent
diagnostics for this.
It probably put some weird characters in
the logs.
Afternoon. Hello.
AI policy.
the less policy enacted around AI, the
better.
And um if they are going to be enacting
stuff
unavoidably,
at the very least making sure that the
stuff that they're aiming that like to
hit Google or OpenAI or Anthropic with
is not hitting anybody that's like
working on 20 GPUs. That's a pretty
important one.
Basically any sort of required
interaction with a government process
for small startups is just going to kill
everything instantly.
generally preventing
like preventing politicians that do not
know anything about tech from screwing
over their entire startup ecosystem
would be good.
It's kind of damage control.
So, it's simultaneously
AI is simultaneously the biggest bubble
and the biggest technological
advancement ever. Um,
it's kind of like the internet but worse
in a sense.
with the internet, it was just, oh, you
know, Ice Breakers has a multi-million
dollar website or whatever.
Like the things that are being done now,
there just so many ways to be stupid
with AI that didn't exist in the '9s.
I also don't think that the big AI CEOs
are going to be remembered fondly for
any of this crap.
Like there's a good chance that we end
up um that we end up
treating the AI execs worse than the
cigarette ad agencies.
like if they just do nothing we will be
fine.
I think it's pretty much the only thing
that they can possibly do is completely
tank the country
Hang on. Give me a second. I'll be right
back.
Yeah, that's an existential risk to the
country though, Jess. like
The good news is unless they do
something absolutely crazy, the RL stuff
we're doing should be unaffected.
Um,
it's like, yay, cool. We're open
sourcing 100,000 parameter policies that
do all sorts of stuff.
that's not really affected by like
restrictions on numbers of GPUs or like
flops or whatever the hell
It just the rule around here is I don't
comment on anything political unless it
is directly and clearly AI.
But yes, that is basically the thing. If
you do nothing in AI for 4 years because
you have it regulated, then uh in four
years this will just be like US will
just be a subsidiary of China or
whatever the [ __ ]
I mean, if you think I'm the goodest
good guy you got, you're seriously
[ __ ]
Uh people are actually aware of AI now
because it's like been jammed down their
throats literally everywhere.
You ride the subway in New York and you
have AI agent ads. It's disgusting.
It's not even an SF. That's New York.
Well, just cuz it just it doesn't do
anything to help the FE like
politicking [ __ ] doesn't help
anything. You're not going to do [ __ ]
there. Like
if you want to actually make a
difference in things, we just build
stuff and release it there. It's
released. It solves X problem. Like
there's no more talking about X problem.
There's no more building a million
companies and fundraising about X
problem. You know, there's no more
regulating around how you can possibly
approach X problem. It's just solved.
Done. Next problem.
Yeah. Again, Anish, like I think if the
outcome of this is that we end up
significantly stying AI progress
um because of what the large companies
have done, like they will be remembered
worse than the cigarette ad agencies. is
the thing that's annoying with Enthropic
is like a lot of them or even most of
them I actually believe that they mean
well. Like I actually do believe that
they mean well. They're just like the
most ludicrously outofouch people you've
ever met who should not ever touch
anything real ever.
I mean, the biggest thing, Jess, is also
that they don't manage to screw up other
areas of AI that are not language models
as Oh,
I mean that's very intense. intentional
ones.
Like my hope is that we eventually we
get this stuff into bio, we get this
into material science. And to be clear,
if I discover good stuff there, a lot of
it will be monetized and it will be
monetized heavily. Um but the goal is
that eventually that aside you know we
end up solving some very important
problems and uh those problems are
solved without piles and piles of
infrastructure that you can never really
understand. You know they're solved um
with just very good sim plus very good
learning
and they're solved in a way that they're
just broadly accessible. Basically
anybody can play with them, extend them,
whatever.
And uh at that point then it becomes
completely apolitical because you can't
like no matter what your views are on
it, you can't do anything about that.
It's just there.
you know, if you come up with um
if you come up with some software for
various forms of like biosim research
and uh it needs to be run on a 10,000
GPU cluster then you know you can do all
sorts of things to make it harder to get
access to that right you know you can
regulate like who has access to the
clusters that are able to do this um if
you have such a cluster who you're able
to allow access to such things with. But
if it's just there and it's like x
number of thousand lines of code and it
runs on your laptop, that's it. You
know, cats out of the bag.
So, I'm basically one of the big reasons
for the way I do my stuff uh this way is
because, you know, even if I end up
hitting walls in my stuff, like it
doesn't make sense for in my mind to try
to solve problems any other way that
requires much larger scale because the
amount of people that get can get in the
way and [ __ ] with you for virtually no
reason is very high. Whereas, I've
essentially optimized for just no
friction, all tech progress. So anything
that I actually come up with, it's just
there.
It's a house in Beverly. Why the hell do
you want a house in Beverly of all
places, my guy?
I also don't need a trillion dollars.
What the [ __ ] would I do with that?
I can invest in SpaceX. I have no idea.
Cred,
I might buy some, but I'm probably not
going to buy some like right on IPO.
I don't particularly like that it's tied
to XAI. Um, I'd be way more excited
about investing if it were not tied to
any of their AI stuff. if it were just
SpaceX,
I got some Nvidia before it like went to
the moon, but I didn't buy anywhere near
enough.
I don't know about that, Jess. Right.
Like maybe AGI can predict the movements
of the stars, but it still can't predict
the madness of men.
I mean, I would believe that XAI could
be very good.
Um,
I think it's pretty clear though that
Elon just has not invested
the
same amount of time into deeply
understanding AI and the stack there as
he has in Tesla and SpaceX.
I mean, you can basically just see that
from like the shifts in the tech stack
and all the like revolving door of
people and all that.
It's funny that they do actually have
the right text stack now in my mind. Um,
but it they probably just have people
vibe coding it like
Yeah.
Clear? Yeah. Okay, we're still here. The
camera just crashed. Let's
Can't hear. You should be able to hear
now. I know it froze.
The stream is not frozen now. It's just
the camera.
There it is.
So, um, yeah, I think that just the
thing that hasn't clicked is like,
you know, more parts is more complexity
generally
when you're working with mechanical
systems.
I don't think that the parts being
dependencies
and you know amount of code and
abstractions like that mapping doesn't
seem like it is clicked yet.
You know it's very easy to explain the
uh importance of minimizing points of
failure in a mechanical system for
instance
and the importance of simplicity is a
very very strong predictor of amount of
[ __ ] that can go wrong.
For whatever reason, it's way harder for
people to grasp this in software.
Some people do, you know, dev their
whole lives and never figure it out.
It's so obvious once you see it as well,
but for whatever even I even remember. I
remember before I saw this and it was
just like so alien.
For whatever reason, software is just
one of those things where like
your natural instinct is to do basically
the dumbest thing possible
Pretty stupid dev day overall, I got to
say. And I have to be done pretty soon
because I got to look at that paper. I'm
hoping we can at least figure out this
one thing.
Like despite all this like crap, I
actually do understand what I'm doing
here and what's going on. Like
essentially what's happening here, okay,
is we swapped from score to advantage as
the thing that tells us what segments to
put in the buffer. And for whatever
reason,
old levels have way higher advantage
than we'd expect.
So, we're not getting the fresh data in
that we actually want. And figuring out
like what data are we actually accepting
and why does it have high value is
really obnoxious. And that's why I have
this stupid back and forth codeex crap
loop.
Most candidates have their max advantage
source and the greater than equal to 90%
solve rate.
Low mean error but non-trivial max
error. Okay.
Maybe we go back to some abs advantage.
A son who talked about attention in
puffer.
I've had a couple people message me like
crackpot attention things that I don't
believe make sense.
That is the dumbest damn exchange. Holy
crap.
It's not even funny. That's just stupid.
Interesting.
So,
yeah, we got stuck for 266 mil on L6
somehow. That'll be useful data.
Blog.
Wait, what blog?
I don't even want to look at that crap.
Come on.
It's stuck for 266 mil by level six.
Huh.
I do remember max advantage being a way
better metric.
No, no, it'll it'll be like, oh, you're
using it. It's fine. Whatever.
What? What is this, dude? Am I going to
regret this?
Oh, it's This is the Geio Hops one.
Fine.
Yeah,
this is actually a pretty reasonable
like
I guess I should have read parts of this
out loud.
But yeah, I mean this is pretty much
spot on.
The only reason in fact like um that
I've been as dependent as I have for uh
the latest puffers because I just need
to invest more time learning lower
learning some lower level dev. Well,
learning CUDA specifically.
I just need to spend some more time on
CUDA so I can get our col our kernels
polished up to the point that
stupid language models
don't keep screwing up my stuff. Link
the article. Just Google internal
sloptember.
It's on par or worse.
But I want to see the specific
latching. That is Russian, isn't it?
You seem kind of sad.
No.
I mean, this is a pretty boring
workflow. I will say I'm kind of just
very slowly slowly chipping away at a
hard problem
and I've been doing it for the last
couple weeks.
Excuse me. We're very close to done.
It's like the last couple questions that
are just tough.
Well, summing is going to favor long
segments.
We can try the mean, but I think that
the length bias is going to screw it up.
No, we're not doing top K mean. That's
[ __ ]
Did they do some abs?
I think they did do some abs in PLR,
right? It was
This could magically just solve it for
us.
does seem kind of crap.
biases you towards very short ones,
right?
It's what they did for PLR though, isn't
it?
they probably have fixed length steps or
some [ __ ] here.
Yeah, some
This isn't massively worse um than I
think this will have to be.
But man, it takes so long to latch. This
could just be we over fit.
I guess we'll see. In my mind, this is
likely the best metric though. Me an
absolute advantage.
pretty irritating.
Get to alpha testing.
This last little chunk is really
annoying, Jess.
I think it's quite possible that like I
just have this thing tuned towards
the previous metric.
Mean abs advantage would have to be
I just don't see how it would be
anything else reasonably.
It is so much worse out the gate though.
Holy crap.
warm start. What do you mean, Jess?
Yeah, we're not we're not doing this
crap.
This should be better than score, not
worse.
Because max is ln, right? So we tried
lin, we tried L1. Why not try L2?
Last run and then we call it.
Last run and we call it. I got no idea
if this doesn't work.
Okay.
Uh, this is reasonable.
We'll see if it solves actually.
This is too much latch.
Does get there eventually.
If I can get 14, I think I can mess with
the prioritization and get 15.
How long has this been running for?
Three, four minutes.
Yeah, I know. It's got too many stats
and it's not displaying cleanly.
I mean, this is a very very long- winded
way of saying ablate L infinity L1 L2,
but eh, we get there.
Hey, we do get 13.
Do we get 14?
We actually have a solve at 14.
Okay, last little bit of analysis. At
least we get some progress today.
It's not latching nicely though.
Presumably data is not getting into the
buffer as cleanly as it should still.
Yeah, we're still 0% on 14.
So
13 with no domain knowledge though is
good
to start.
Oh, hang on. Does it solve right at the
end?
It's very close to solving.
Hey, Liberty.
Oh, come on.
There we go.
Yeah.
Okay, that's 14 with no domain
knowledge.
Do we actually get a result today? Just
barely
Yeah, we just didn't get the 15 solve
cuz the other ones took too long to
latch.
I do need to get ready to go, but man,
we just got uh we just got the the
result.
It's so close.
I'm not going to work on this later
either because I'm getting margaritas
with a friend who does work on CL.
Don't worry badge, it's all diagnostics.
Um, none of that crap is getting kept.
In fact, like none of this stuff is just
going to be merged to puffer. Um, it's
mainly this is we figure out algorithm.
We're going to automated debloat a lot
of it and then I'm going to manually
rewrite the thing before this gets into
the actual codebase.
The reason I'm doing [ __ ] this way is
that this is still faster. Like here, I
could very easily prototype this stuff
in torch manually, but then the runs
would take like 20 minutes. So, it's
better that I have this thing just add
diagnostics and stuff in 2 minutes and
then I run it in 6 That's
Uh Jess, we have 14 score with no domain
knowledge.
It's going to still need some work, but
we're very close.
The trick was to use L2 of the value
error, not L1.
L1 is too um
sensitive to noise.
So,
one seemingly quite simple trick
Okay, I think I'm happy with this for
now. Um,
just there's still a lot to ablate. It's
not getting 15 out of 15 levels. Um, I
don't like the way that we are updating
the advantage estimates and the
sampling, the distribution for sampling
as well. There's still quite a bit of
work. Yes, that's the point, Liberty.
The whole point of what I'm doing is to
be able to imply it like to everything
in Puffer.
We did make a nice big jump in progress
at the end there. I mean, that might
have seemed obvious like, oh yeah, trial
infinity, trial one, try what? But like
the reasoning behind it took a while.
All right,
so
I'm going to call it here. Um, decent
stream.
Still kind of tired today. We'll start
this back on Monday. Thank you everybody
for tuning in. I just did push it, Jess.
If I don't know if this version is going
to be any better, but this is just with
batch size bigger. Um,
thank you everybody for tuning in. It's
on the CLX branch. Uh, if you're
interested in my work generally and
you'd like to support the project for
absolutely free, just our puffer on
GitHub. Also YouTube, you can sub there.
Uh, Twitter or X, you can follow me
there. Discord's where all the dev
happens. Join there if you want.
Discord.gg/puffer.
All sorts of fun demos on the website.
We stream all sorts of research around
here. Sometimes it's fast, sometimes
it's slow, but we make progress
nonetheless. Enjoy your week.